فيصل عبد الساتر من جديد اعود اليك اذا
اذا كانت كل التحليلات تذهب باتجاه ان
نتنياهو يريد استدراج حزب الله الى معركه
اوسع الى اي مدى يمكن ان يحتفظ هنا حزب
الله بحق الرد في المكان والزمان
المناسبين ويبقي على جبهه الجنوب كما هي
حاليا في اطارها العسكري ري والجغرافي الى
ان يحين موعد اكثر مناسبه له للرد على
عمليه
الاغتيال انا اجزم لك بان جبهه الجنوب لن
تتوقف وربما تتصاعد فيها العمليات
العسكريه بصرف النظر الان عن الموقف من
العمليه عمليه الاغتيال نفسها لان هذا
الامر له حساب اخر في عقليه حزب الله وفي
منهجيه حزب الله وكما تفضلت في ان الصفحه
مفتوحه لازالت في موضوع له علاقه بعماد
مغنيه ونجل عماد مغنيه ومصطفى بدر الدين
وقيادات من حزب الله لم يعلن حزب الله الى
الان ان العمليات التي يعني ممكن ان يقوم
بها ردا على هذه الاغتيالات قد حان وقتها
وربما يعني هذا يراه هو في اي وقت يعني
تتناسب فيه الظروف مع مثل هذا الامر لكن
هذا لا يعني ابدا اننا في هذه الحاله
مختلفه نحن نتحدث الان عن مع ركه ومجزره
متماد في غزه نتحدث عن اعتقالات واسعه في
الضفه نتحدث عن جبهه مشتعله في البحر
الاحمر ونتحدث عن الجبهه اللبنانيه بما
لها من امتدادات على على يعني على مدار
150 م وتتوسع شيئا فشيئا نتنياهو الذي كان
بالامس يقول انه لا يريد ان يفتح جبهه حرب
واسعه مع لبنان اليوم بهذا الاغتيال ربما
اراد يعني يعني كما قلت قبل ان تقطع معي
الحديث وتنتقل الى الضيفين الكريمين قلت
ان نتنياهو يريد ان يظهر بصوره نصر
وربما استشهاد صالح العاروري سيكون هذا
هذه او هذه الصوره من النصر التي يريدها
نتنياهو وبالتالي هذه ستحفز على ان يكون
في مامن من الاشكاليات والارباك داخل
الحكومه الصهيونيه على المستوى الداخلي
لكن هذا لن يغير في واقع الحل هل ان هذه
الحرب ستقف عند هذا الحد هل هذا سيكون
مخرج لبدايه عمليه تفاوض واسعه ودخول
وسطاء
ودبلوماسيين ربما لبنان موعود بجزء منهم
وربما العاصمه القطريه وربما العاصمه
المصريه هذه اسئله لا يستطيع احد الان على
الساخن ان يجيب عنها ويقول ان راس صالح
العاروري رحمه الله سيكون هو المخرج لهذه
الحرب انا باعتقادي ان مثل هذا الامر قد
يكون معيب في هذه اللحظه طرحه من هذه
الزاويه لوحدها نعم بالنسبه
للاسرائيليين ان نقبل بان الامر قد يكون
مخرجا في هذا الاطار لابد لنا ايضا ان
نعبر عن صوره ما من صور القوه تجاه هذا
الاغتيال وهذه الصوره قادر عليها الان هي
هذا المحور مجتمعا كل في ساحته وفقا
للامكانيات المتوفره هو شكل هذه
الصوره ما هو شكل هذه الصوره هذه الصوره
انا الان انا هذا افترض ان شكل هذه الصوره
قد ياتي مجتمعا الان قد يكون من البحر
الاحمر قد يكون من القواعد الامريكيه في
العراق قد يكون من الساحه اللبنانيه
باتجاه عمق الجليل وما بعد الجليل قد يكون
اقول قد لانه هذا الامر افترضه على هذا
النحو والا والا عمليا يكون الاسرائيلي قد
اظهر مزيد من الانقسام في لبنان قد جعل
الدوله في مكان والمقاومه في مكان وبعض
الاطراف السياسيه في مكان والبعض ممكن ان
يشمت ايضا ويقول ان هذا المسؤول الكبير من
حماس اغتيل في قلب الضاحيه الجنوبيه وانتم
تريدون الذهاب الى القدس في حفله شماته
اضافيه يعني انا اقول
لك ل نختصر ما تقوله كانك تقول اما الذهاب
نحو توسيع الحرب وحرب شامله وعلى اكثر من
محور وكل وفق قدرته مهما كان الرد
الاسرائيلي المقابل واما ان تكون اسرائيل
قد انتصرت بعمليه الاغتيال هذه هذه هي
الفكره بالمختصر
لا لا لا لا لا لي ليس بهذه الصوره انا
كنت اقول انه من واجب المحور ان يقوم بما
بمقدوره ان يقوم به وهذا امر تقرره كل
ساحه لكن بالنسبه للساحه اللبنانيه لا
اريد ان استبق حزب الله لكن اقول لك بكل
ثقه ان حزب الله سيكون له كلام اخر في هذه
العمليه